assurance chômage formation
professionnelle apprentissage le
programme de l'atelier citoyen organisé
par le député yves binois jean-noël
barrot avec comme invité de marque la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
le but c'est effectivement d'avoir un
dialogue c'est à dire que la ministre va
nous expliquer le contenu de ce projet
de loi puisque il n'est pas encore tout
à fait connu enfin ne vient d'être connu
et puis ces deux d'avoir les réactions
des uns et des autres pour pouvoir
effectivement le moment venu l'enrichir
lors du débat parlementaire s'engager
pour la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel c'est le nom de ce projet
de loi préparé par la ministre
plusieurs mesures prévues dans ce texte
notamment garantir l'assurance chômage
pour les démissionnaires et les
travailleurs indépendants sous certaines
conditions ou encore simplifier l'accès
à des formations professionnelles
conçoit salariés qu'on soit demandeur
d'emploi on veut pouvoir choisir sa voie
professionnelle et pas simplement subir
des changements c'est la meilleure
protection contre le chômage c'est la
formation originale c'est pour ça qu'on
veut investir à fond sur ce sujet autres
points évoqués dans les discussions
l'apprentissage plusieurs modifications
envisagées notamment donner la
possibilité aux entreprises ou à une
branche professionnelle de créer son
propre centre de formation des apprentis
je pense que l'apprentissage aujourd'hui
c'est la voie royale pour réussir et
notamment pour intégrer nos futurs
apprenants qui effectivement peuvent
envisager par la suite une poursuite
d'études professionnelles dans ce cas
dit la ministre ce soir c'est du grand
flou c'est beaucoup de 10 des déjà
entendu on va faire mieux avec moins
pour plus le problème c'est que on nous
parle de simplification est aujourd'hui
le système de financement peut paraître
complexe pour les gens qui ne
connaissent rien mais en fait ils
fonctionnent très bien
ce texte de loi doit être transmis pour
avis au conseil d'état il devrait être
présenté au parlement au début du mois
de mai